könig der ort couture mode zar und
visionär für karl lagerfeld ist kaum
eine beschreibung zu groß wie das
modehaus chanel mitteilte verstarb der
designer der die modewelt über
jahrzehnte maßgeblich prägte am dienstag
lagerfeld kam in hamburg zur welt 1954
gewann er mit einem entwurf für einen
mantel einen wettbewerb und erhielt
daraufhin eine stelle beim französischen
designer pia palme
anschließend arbeitete er für das
modehaus chloé bevor er zur
italienischen marke fendi wechselte ab
1983 war lagerfeld kreativdirektor bei
chanel
dort erlangte er bald den status einer
legende und wurde mit spitznamen wie
kaiser karl bedacht das revival von
chanel in den 1980 er jahren wird
maßgeblich karl lagerfeld zugeschrieben
unverkennbar war er durch sein outfit
das aus dunkler sonnenbrille weiß
gepudert dem zopf schwarzem anzug und
einem hemd mit vatermörder kragen
bestand zeitweilig gehörte auch ein
schwarzer fächer dazu berühmt wurde er
auch durch seine bissigen äußerungen und
seine selbstironie nach dem
bekanntwerden des todes von karl
lagerfeld verneigte sich die welt vor
der mode ikone claudia schiffer jahre
lang die muse von karl lagerfeld teilte
mit karl lagerfeld sei das gewesen was
andy warhol für die kunst war er sei der
einzige mensch gewesen der aus schwarz
und weiß etwas farbenfrohes herstellen
konnte
der vorstandschef von chanel anna
wertheimer sagte lagerfeld sei dank
seines kreativen genies seiner
großzügigkeit und seiner
außergewöhnlichen intuition seiner zeit
voraus gewesen er habe maßgeblich zum
weltweiten erfolg des modehauses
beigetragen
auch schauspieler sängerinnen und andere
prominente verabschiedeten sich auf den
sozialen netzwerken würde nie war seit
über 30 jahren engste mitarbeiterin von
lagerfeld soll nun die kreativen
arbeiten für die kollektionen übernehmen
französische medien berichteten
lagerfeld sei am dienstagmorgen
gestorben nachdem er am vorabend in
einem krankenhaus in new jersey in der
nähe von paris eingeliefert worden sei
gerüchte über seinen gesundheitszustand
hatten bereits die runde gemacht nachdem
er der januar show von chanel in paris
ferngeblieben war
über sein alter hatte lagerfeld die welt
stets im unklaren gelassen es gilt als
wahrscheinlich dass er
1933 geboren wurde doch auch 1935 und 38
kursierten in den medien als
geburtsjahre karl lagerfeld wurde 85
jahre alt